hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video wisst
freunde heute ist zwar nicht dienstag
aber donnerstag weil ich das irgendwie
verschieben musste wegen ablaufplan weil
ich gerade im urlaub bin allerdings
kommt heute in minecraft video uncut das
habe ich in der letzten folge schon
gesagt letzte woche dienstag habe ich
auch schon umgesetzt dass ab dem moment
jetzt wird weiter gehen also jetzt bitte
nicht mehr geschnitten also los geht's
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich gerade hey
wieso ist denn luca hier unten in seiner
höhle und ohne items weil aus der
letzten folge wissen luca hat sich
irgendwo anders in der höhle ausgeloggt
und hatte krasse items und alles und war
alles super toll ich bin ich ich muss
euch dann eine kleine story zu erzählen
darüber handelt dieses video jetzt
eigentlich müsste ich mich dafür auch
mal eben schnell töten von irgendwem
damit ich wieder oben bin da kommt ein
skelett das doch super gelegenheit hier
kommt jetzt umlauf mich nicht sondern
töte mich vielleicht einfach mal schnell
genauso schließlich ab super ich mich
nochmal ab danke schießt mir vielleicht
noch ein viertes mal ab dankeschön dafür
fünf das geht auch noch dankeschön
sechster muss drin sein kollege sechster
ist am start
sie macht auch danke jetzt kommt ein
achter kaum machen achten
ach und da der neunte macht den neunten
dankeschön ich bin meine damen und
herren ich respawnen an meinem bett
es ist nacht raus das heißt je mal ganz
kurz plätze ich euch mal ganz gut dass
ich keine items mehr habe dass ich
gestorben bin dass ich mich jetzt von
einem skelett aufdecken lassen weil ich
die tür nicht zugebaut habe ich doch
blöd man das ist natürlich klar dass ich
das wieder nicht gebacken kriegen hier
liegen die sorgen autor ist tot
jetzt nehme ich mir mal einfach von hier
irgend ein bisschen erde und klatschte
bei mir wieso
so wächst hier gras schneiden und mich
kurz sammeln und möchte geschichte
gleich zu präsentieren weil ein bisschen
traurig ist aber ich hab ja ich
geschworen ich werde in diesem projekt
nicht schneiden
also folgende story freunde zum
morgengrauen da oben könnte ich auch
pendler müssen wir doch endlich mal die
ganze kacke da so ein bisschen richtig
bauen
mir fällt ein bisschen schwer dass ihr
bei der höhleneingang wo wir drin
standen bzw in der höhle in der wir ganz
tief drin waren
ich bin jetzt ich habe gerade schon
gezockt nicht weil ich mir gedacht habe
okay cool so nice ich kann mich nicht
zurückhalten
sie zocken bis ich wieder im video
aufnehmen sondern vielmehr aus dem grund
weil ich auch aufgenommen habe
ich hab halt echt überhaupt kein team
ist alles mitgenommen und dann dachte
ich mir halt so ok lukas ist gerade
donnerstag erstmals grund warum das
video heute kommt und nicht am dienstag
weil am dienstag ein pokémon gold das
wollte ich unbedingt an dem dienstag
auch hochladen weil mir das video
einfach spaß macht und ich habe extra
die nacht durchgemacht deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht da kommt bestimmt nicht wenn
das video am donnerstag nicht am
dienstag kommt das war erstmal so die
sache warum das video jetzt kommt und ja
ich da gerade halt so das video
aufgenommen irgendwie vor einer
viertelstunde ganze video aufgenommen
und irgendwann so nachziehen
15 minuten fällt bilder auf einmal so
auf luca
so sage ich die face camp so ich habe
einfach vergessen
die facetime aufzunehmen und das wäre an
sich gewesen wenn ich normal das
spielgeschehen kommentiert hätte
allerdings geht es im video auch darum
meine haare die jetzt viel kürzer sind
und ich habe ein bisschen interagiert
mit base camp unseren chat und hat doch
mal reingeguckt irgendwann fällt mir auf
dass so eine kleine rote leuchte bei
meinem facetime programm und die war
gelb und das bedeutet halt so ja die
kennen die scheiße und da muss ich ein
update mal deswegen konnte ich aufnehmen
das habe ich gegen in dem moment wo ich
aufgenommen habe habe ich das ja gar
nicht so richtig mitbekommen und warte
ich hab grad ich bekomme ich erst mal
ganz kurz an
scheißegal meine mama günstigen raus
fertig ich dann auf jeden fall so
gedacht ok hinderlich in der folge sogar
noch gesagt okay freunde ich habe die
ganze zeit bisher keine face cam drin so
ist natürlich blöd aber ich hoffe ihr
genießt das video trotzdem jetzt noch
weiter aber das ist mir aufgefallen okay
es wäre alles wirklich überhaupt keinen
film gewesen wenn ich nicht so viel über
die facetime kommuniziert hätte sage ich
mal
und das war halt
wirklich blöd von mir sage ich mal
deswegen kurzfassung ich habe vorhin
aufgenommen und als mitten im video
aufgefallen die facetime ist garnicht
alter mit ihr freuen wir sind gewachsen
ist wundervoll
die face käme es gar nicht an ein
bisschen blöd jetzt wenn ich mich die
ganze zeit wirklich auf diese beziehe
wie kann seine sexy bälle hinten und ich
längst dies baut ist das frage ich mich
auch gerade so ein bisschen so ich schob
sich erstmal dahin weg halte ich hatte
einfach ein eisen schwert und nur sachen
und jetzt bin ich wieder bei backsteine
das packt mich auch ein bisschen ab hab
mir dann halt so gedacht die ja dann bin
ich jetzt halt das video allerdings
müsst ihr halbwissen jetzt damit ich
endlich auf den punkt kommen und ich bin
kein guter typ darin auf den punkt zu
kommen
ich habe das video naja ich bin in dem
video gestorben
in der höhle ich von einer klippe
gefallen bin
und falls ihr euch jetzt nachdem luca
dem verarscht uns das stimmt doch gar
nicht lügt man nicht so rum vier
blödmann die ihre kannst ja auch das
einmalige ausgedacht haben einfach
gerade in die welt gegangen sein und
dann gesehen haben dass ein comeback
spendiert hat so gar nicht aufgenommen
so dass freunde weil ich die birne oder
nicht blöd freunde ich verabscheue ich
nicht ich habe ja aufgenommen das heißt
ich habe noch die aufnahme datei das
heißt ich werde dieses projekt jetzt
einmal schneiden und euch jetzt gerade
die fehler reinpacken in der ich nicht
da kommt gerade in trieb heraus alter
ich stelle mich mal ganz kurz ich weiß
nicht wie ich auf pause gehen
ok nichts bewegt sich ich töte mal ganz
kurz dem hyper dahin und danach wenn ich
euch die copd ist tot der bibel bekannt
sein dass sie unten einfach die höhle
bauen das alles wo ich hinwollte
ich glaube schon
ich habe keine ahnung
es war dann auf jeden fall so ich habe
das ganze aufgenommen um auf den punkt
zu kommen ich habe das ganze aufgenommen
das heißt ich blende euch jetzt hier mal
eine szene einmal pause
ich blende euch jetzt jene szene ein von
der aufnahme die ich vorhin gemacht habe
wo allerdings die fans kann ich am start
war wo ich gestorben bin damit ihr seht
wie ich gestorben bin
ja ich stand da hat sachen abgebaut und
dachte mir nur so okay ich bin jetzt
unten ins wasser und ich kenne es halten
horst den jetzigen minecraft version
mann springt ins wasser und man essay
wenn man im wasser landet allerdings ist
es in dieser version wieso man muss ihn
perfekt großes wasser springen und
deswegen bin ich halt gestorben und dann
ist mir dann nachhaltigen aufgefallen
ich gucke und die facetime denkt so oft
faktisch aber gar nicht facebook
aufgenommen gestorben komme ich da drin
steht jetzt einfach neu deswegen jetzt
weiter an katja so hat sich der ganze
haase dann quasi entwickelt also da
befinden wir uns jetzt ich hab' keine
items mehr meine sachen sind irgendwo
unten in irgendeiner höhle die ich jetzt
nicht mehr finde ich habe jetzt auch
keinen bock mehr die andere die aufnahme
noch mal anzugucken wie in die höhle
gekommen weil ich direkt davor mich
ausgelaugt habe ich kenne auch keine
daten mehr wiegen wieder hinkommen oder
so ich kann nur hoffen dass deutschland
gerade nicht genau der ist in dem ich
mich gerade befinde weil ich glaube
dieser version ist es so dass die items
die s-bahnen wenn sie im gleichen junk
sind ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
stimmt oder ob ich gerade in schwachsinn
fertig macht jetzt übrigens auch mal so
damit ich das vielleicht endlich mal
finde
setz dich jetzt an jedem gang in dem ich
schon mal so einen kostenblock hier ist
nichts drin glaube ich nicht ist nichts
drin aber nur items dieser gang
da weiß ich schon dass ich eigentlich
nicht sein wird weil der gang führt nur
wieder zu einem anderen gang habe ich
nehm jetzt auch mal das komplette reise
mit weil ich hab ja nichts mehr
es ist auch nicht so toll aber mein gott
ich kann jetzt nichts dran ändern
und ja ich könnte natürlich auch trauern
weil ich hatte viel gold und so ich
wusste zwar etwas mit gold hätte machen
sollen
aber es war halt wichtig hatte lapis und
so unglaublich viel von allen möglichen
items und vor allem eisen hals was das
grund alt ist um die ausrüstung bauen zu
bauen und so hatte ich halt alles dabei
ein bisschen traurig dass ich jetzt tot
bin ich traurig klar wenn man mich fragt
luca bis zu traurig natürlich klar aber
es gibt schlimmeres im leben voll nehmen
und ich sehe schon kommen dieser gang
wieder genau der gang hat auch wieder
eine sackgasse in sich drehen hier
nochmal ein bisschen kohle mit ob ich
will es auch nicht ganz die kohle mit
einem in dieser folge sondern eigentlich
nur versuchen meine sachen
wiederzufinden
im titel steht wahrscheinlich ich bin
gestorben oder so und ihr habt gehofft
dass was passieren
ich war nur items oder so aber habe ich
mich nicht durch sein wenn ich gerade
beschossen
von dem boot
eva king baby so beschließt ihr mich
denn jetzt auch noch ich hab das schon
lange jetzt ist eine mücke ich von
heulen gibt schon einen ganzen land
verloren jetzt ich hab' ich habe nichts
zu essen mitgenommen mama das briefing
immer spaß macht ich sogar schon tempel
vorgesetzte sonnenschein aber auch jetzt
ist sie wieder so ein riesiges dinge von
darum bin ich das sogar gekommen
donald creeper immer noch weh wie soll
ich den ersten siegen auch ein zombie
hey wie gehts dir das war auf jeden fall
die story so warum ich gestorben bin
auch was wollt ihr denn alle hier schild
doch eure ja dann bleibt halt da wird
auf jeden fall eure base und lass mich
in ruhe
mann ich weiß nicht wo ich eine spinne
die monster partie alles klar zwei
skelette bruder also überhaupt kein ding
das duo mein gott da unten jetzt relativ
weit runter ich weiß nicht was wollt ihr
eigentlich wollt ihr mich jetzt auch
noch töten oder was noch mehr zur lief
wahrscheinlich noch mehr zombies oder ok
eineinhalb herzen einmal vom skelett
getroffen werden ich bin tot
mein gott ich kann halt nicht mehr
aufladen
ich kann diese scheiße hier fressen
freunde mein leben ist vorbei
mein leben ist vorbei
wie soll ich aus dieser situation bitte
jemals rauskommen meine mutter schreibt
mir etwas mit einem einkaufsliste oder
so was wieder so helm ich bin gerade in
minecraft ein halbes herz ohne witz ich
könnte jetzt irgendwo im graben oder so
aber was hätten denn ein nicht zu essen
mitzunehmen
ob mein gott okay ich habe ein bisschen
ich habe ein bisschen was fühlt sich
damit schon mein leben auf bitte
nein anscheinend nicht verwischte packe
ich muss irgendwie nach oben kommen ohne
zu sterben
ob ein skelett ins gesetz ein skelett
nicht weglaufen ich kann aber nicht
laufen
was tue ich
ich könnte theoretisch ich könnte hoffen
dass ich den vom be here töten kann und
von ihm fleisch bekomme genau ich habe
fleischer jetzt noch zwei tropfen können
gerne
ich hab das ich brauche noch ein fleisch
oder 2 und dann habe ich so viel wieder
dass ich meine leben ausfüllen können
nur fleisch zu bekommen benötige ich
zombies
unter schock
es ist es hier wenn jedoch sand ist mein
gott oh mein gott oberfläche freunde
sind gerettet
wir sind so gut wie gerettet oh mein
gott und das ist herrlich tattag alter
ihr ahnt ist nicht ihre art ich wo ich
bin direkt unter meinem haus oh mein
gott wie kann man sein glück haben wie
ich hat in dieser situation ok erstmal
schön waren das schon wieder
nahtoderfahrungen heute alltag scharf
töte dich mal ganz kurz die bruckberger
kennt fressen hier
ich könnte heulen maniche können die
ganze zeit schon heute okay es wird
nacht ich muss eigentlich schlafen gehen
ich guck doch mal ganz kurz ob ich hier
nicht irgendwas zu fressen haben zwei
rotten flesh
hab die ganzen brot habe ich mir auch
mitgenommen so okay wenn alles gut läuft
überlebe ich damit diese nacht und auch
wenn ich hier sterbe freunde dass wir
auch keinen ding weil ich ja jetzt
zuhause wisst ihr okay mein leben fühlt
sich aber auf ich werde mir das hier zu
schauen mich ins bett gelegen
auch iran ist nicht schon wieder freunde
alter was haben wir bitten diese folgen
wieder erlebt das waren nicht nur normal
wenn es wenigstens so gewesen wäre das
in dieser folge gestorben wäre oder
nicht meine sachen sucht okay aber auch
mein es wieder abgezogen sich gerade
aber es war halt so dass ich
sind das hier brauchen die höhe oder was
gott ey freunde der sonne ist dort alles
kritisch
mann mann mann freund wieder
runterkommen über die angeht ja leider
noch nicht wie komme ich darunter freuen
dich scheiße doch einfach aufessen wisst
ihr ich hab nur essen gebraucht weil ich
kein leben mehr hatte weil da ja diese
ganzen kombis auf einer gekommen sind
steht komplett neben der spur
da unten ist er gestorben glaube ich
skelette sowas ja vielleicht hingekriegt
habe es bringt aber gerade auch nichts
weil ich ja essen benötige einfach
beziehungsweise nicht unbedingt essen
aber meine sachen einfach wieder und ich
weiß einfach nicht ob ich da im gleichen
okay von da bin ich auch schon mal
runter gegangen hat das war der eingang
von davon
das ist alles ein riesiges
höhlensystemen er ist euch das mal
aufgefallen übels ihre immer wieder weg
hier
ich muss nur irgendwie meine damen
finden ich bin echt schon kurz davor
einfach in die letzte folge zu schauen
und dann mal nachzugucken aber ich bin
einfach viel ambitionierter gerade
hinsichtlich der tatsache dass ich meine
sachen finde als das ok zombie du könnte
vielleicht ein bisschen rock session
lust habt danke zwei stücke das super
kennt ihr das eigentlich den euro
muskeln zucken ich hab das vor läuft
hinten am 1
an meiner linken seite da an meiner
linken wie heißt als schulter das
einfach so der schulter muskel zog die
ganze zeit und ich denke mir nur so die
unity freshminds bei scream und juni zum
diamond mein gott oh mein gott oh mein
gott holy holy shit [ __ ] [ __ ] my world
okay
einfach weg sackgasse
ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich mich in
meinen kräften so sehr erschrecken kann
wie in dieser situation gerade alter ich
beende gleich sofort den part macht mir
kurz was zu essen kommen bisschen klaus
mein leben und nehmen an dem part für
nächste woche auch weil ihr wisst ja ich
bin grad am vorproduzieren für weil ich
im urlaub bin gerade und eigentlich
wollte ich in diesem tatort noch über
die themen reden dass der friseur meine
friese komplett verpackt hat er hat echt
übel verkackt er das fakt nicht ultra
abgeraten
und hey ich bin morgen wohl ab und alles
war
freunde mein leben ist gerade echt am
ende sowieso ein bisschen ich fahre hier
die ganze kohle links steht welche
monster die mich töten wollte mich
überhaupt nicht gerne haben kein essen
mit wahrscheinlich meine ganze sache die
sport ich dachte dieser folge finden
diamant und alles getan aber auch das
eisen hiermit da ist noch mehr eisen
wahrscheinlich ist darunter auch noch
lava so wie ich mein glück gerade kenne
da haben wir ein bisschen mehr eisen
hier am start
jemandem natürlich eine höhle wenn ich
da rein gefallen wer mit einem herzen er
ich habe geheult gestorben so was haben
wir hier nichts oder war schon eine
fackel okay das ist schön
ich will am liebsten würde immer weiter
erkunden warum kommt da springt nicht
direkt eine spinne hier an freunde
ich stehe jetzt hier ich logge mich aus
so alles gut wenn euch dieser part
vielleicht gefallen hat lasst doch gerne
bewertet wir sehen uns nächste woche
dienstag in dem video wieder fällig